- Son salon est aménagé
en salle de méditation. Robert
Tsao pratique l'art du zen dans
la pièce surplombant le parc
Daan, grand parc de Taipei.
Défendre Taïwan, selon lui,
est son devoir de bouddhiste.
Celui de prévenir un
désastre pointant à l'horizon.
Inspiré par la résilience
ukrainienne, le milliardaire
taïwanais promet de donner
100 millions de dollars
américains pour former
les civils au combat.
Trois millions dpepersonnes en
trois ans, dont 300 000 tireurs
d'élite.
Il souhaite développer
à Taïwan la détermitition
et une plus grande volonté
de défendre l'île.
C'est d'autant plus important,
selon lui, que le président
chinois, Xi Jinping, vient
d'obtenir unroroisième mandat.
"Je pense qu'il a eu le mandat
pour réaliser l'annexion
de Taïwan."
Le milliardaire
de l'électronique a déjà
contourné les lois pour
brasser des affaires en Chine.
Il avait renoncé
à sa citoyenneté taïwanaise
jusqu'à récemment. Mais Robert
Tsao est maintenant en croisade
contre les communistes chinois
qu'il qualifient de zombies.
Et contre le président chinois,
Xi Jinping, responsable,
selon lui, du démantèlement
de Hong Kong et de possibles
crimes contre l'humanité
nsns le Xinjiang.
Taïwan joue un rôle
crucial dans la production
des microprocesseurs,
ce qui inciterait les États-Unis
et le Japon à se porter
à sa défense, selon plusieurs
analystes. Mais attention
à cette notion de bouclier de
silicium, avertit Robert Tsao.
La Chine pourrait tout
aussi prendre en otage TSMC,
le plus gros joueur mondial
des semiconducteurs,
afin d'obtenir le contrôle
de Taïwan en échange.
Des propos qui tranchent
à Taïwan. La majorité
des résidents affirment
qu'ils sont habitués
aux menaces ininoises et
qu'ils ne sont pas inquiets.
"Un faux sentiment de sécurité",
selon lui. La preuve que
les mentalités doivent changer.
Pratiquer le zen et
le bouddhisme, c'est vivre
dans le moment présent et
la menac